oh man
that outfit I love this scene
I love the door melange's little tits to
each other she goes and then they all
disappear their voice commanded
this is high this is amazing
turn
s
you don't bite them oh no fast
do not make us feel
the drama the Intrigue I mean I would
have loved to see some Royal drama for
sure they wouldn't have warned anyone
else it's because it's a koi they would
have just killed yeah yeah they all have
so much respect for her so much
that outfit I can't get over her
different
I know it's yeah it's a lot before we
continue we want to thank nordvpn for
sponsoring our show today more on them
in a bit we must perform the rich
I
I like this guy
I don't want you to step forward
all the outfits are so good I know I
know I would love more of this in the
movie
I don't
think we should have had it's not
betrayed
traitor is this is their ritual this is
their tradition that's how they do it
yeah I think it's just like that she
stood for these people and then just to
go and fight for fight them
I Love This Game of Thrones
yeah fight each other
will you go
whatever my new spacesuit takes me girl
to space he said it was ugly
Dora anymore
um I want to know where Okoye is going
next I think
this is now because she freed him she's
I thought he was going back to wakanda
but clearly he's not we need we need
answers Marvel hey welcome back to new
rock stars black panther what kind of
forever is now on Disney plus coming to
Blu-ray very soon we just learned of a
deleted subplot that would have shown
okoye's plot to usurp the Throne of
wakanda should okoya become queen or
even the next Black Panther and what's
next for her in the MCU wakanda
this is inside Marvel it's new
Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction show
I'm Eric boss I'm here with Jessica
Clemens Mt is off this week but we are
lucky to have joining us a good friend
of the channel an expert in gaming all
things Marvel all the way from the spare
bedroom of the kind of funny Channel Tim
Gettys thank you guys so much for having
me I'm a huge huge fan of new rockstars
I am fanboying out a little bit right
now so so thank you for having me oh
we're a fan going out for you too I mean
look at that look at that beautiful
background that you were in can we can
we just transport ourselves there just
there's got to be a back door to the
blue dungeon over to this Fair bedroom
right uh yeah I'm kind of trapped here I
live here now so I gotta stick with what
I got
well y'all are welcome here anytime in
San Francisco well we're so excited to
have you on today Tim there's a lot to
talk about and we're very excited what
kind of forever is now streaming Jessica
is going to be doing a re-breakdown of
the film all the new Easter eggs you can
see in 4k stuff that we've learned from
the screenplay from the deleted scenes
from the podcast Jess can you give us a
little uh to use of what we can look
forward to from that video oh my gosh
there's so much I I think we've said it
a lot and I'm gonna say it again please
go listen to the wakanda forever podcast
there's so much in-depth stuff that
you're missing and especially with the
production designer who created a 400
page Bible for the talokins and that she
gives a lot of information as to like
where they are how they got there
technologically and how they advance so
quickly it is so important to go see
that and I will bring it into the
re-release breakdown because a lot of
new stuff is in there oh Jessica can't I
can't wait to see I'm so excited another
little plug here be sure to check out
new rockstarsmerch.com where you can
always grab the latest and greatest new
Rockstar's gear our merch Partners have
recently changed their name to nerd Riot
and we are working closely with them to
develop more exciting merch options
right now you can check out our newest
line of Ant-Man the WASP Quantum Mania
inspired merch and if you order now you
can get the merchant time for the
Ant-Man and the wasconomy opening
weekend support the channel check out
our great merch options over at
norexresmerch.com all right our topic
today should koye have become wakanda's
Queen in the film Ramona tells akoye
that she could visit her treacherous
husband anytime she likes virtual okabe
Daniel khaliga was not in the sequel but
it implied that he still lives in Exile
somewhere in the Border tribe
establishing maybe a bit of a political
Strife between the crown between the
throne and those on the border tribe the
way is often the case in kingdoms people
who live on the borders are kind of like
yeah whatever you technically rule over
our territories but we kind of do our
own thing over here at least that's what
Florida does you know they're kind of a
lawless land in my homeland where really
I think a couple different cities are
ruled over by by alligators as Mayors
they actually do a better job than the
humans in that state but that's just my
opinion we get these deleted scenes that
are fascinating to watch and clean this
moment between Okoye and uh in the head
of the of the Border tribe in which he
makes a strong push for her to challenge
for the throne I personally think he's
right I think shuri's War charge against
Neymar was a bit misguided at least at
that point you know she was still Guided
by revenge in the spirit of killmonger
and it really was only because of her
connection with really with Namor and
their shared Mutual loss of their
mothers that they're able to reach this
piece in this treaty but I think akoye
might make a better Black Panther and a
better ruler of wakanda that's just my
take though I want to hear what both of
you think and what you think might be
next for Okoye in the MCU I
um I agree that she would make a great
black panther but I think the one of the
scenes that really got me in wakanda
Forever was how she begged uh ramonda
for her spot back to please let her die
as a warrior and I think that gives way
to how long she's been adore milage and
how much it meant to her and I think the
dorm Elijah comes first and their vision
of being like we protect wakanda and we
protect a throne and I think that's so
embedded into her that she's like I
don't want to be Queen because I want to
protect the throne I don't want to be
the throne I want to be there to help
not to be the one that steers the entire
ship and even though
um shuri did have fault like the bad
judgment even though she did rule with
like anger Revenge I think the same
could still be said for Okoye when she
lost uh shuri and then she also like
they brought up how she teamed with like
her husband who was a betrayer and it's
like what happens when that happens
again who are you gonna stand with the
people or what our mission was and those
are difficult things for her to
differentiate so I don't think she
should have been Queen
yeah you know it's it's interesting
there because like I I feel like we all
know obviously the the wakanda forever
story of getting to that movie there was
like a lot of of hardships and issues to
to work through but it's still so
surprising to me to see these deleted
scenes and have them be so radically
different than what we actually see in
the the final movie in terms of plot
points and where they were going and
this kind of is evidence to the the idea
that they weren't maybe sure even of who
was going to rule and who was going to
lead but I do think that Marvel knows
that uh Okoye is a fan favorite right
and she's been so well built up in the
both the Panther movie but then also in
the an Infinity war and things like that
so I feel like the fans would want her
to be the leader and I feel like it
would make sense with how they built it
up of how cool she is and how like how
much of a warrior she actually is and
how much she actually loves wakanda and
understands it and we see a lot of that
in the first movie
um when killmonger does take over and
the struggle she has to deal with that I
feel like she is capable of being a
great leader and I feel like she I feel
like she'd be a really good pick for
this yeah I what I like about the way
they're building up uh Okoye in the
subplot and I assume this subplot was
initially intended maybe to set up for
this Okoye spin-off series that I think
is in the works over at Disney plus is a
sense of Mobility for the character like
she's not bound to the nation of wakanda
or to its Customs she can kind of you
know she I think when she's shirking
that responsibility it's not because she
doesn't care about wakanda quite the
contrary right but I just think she set
her sights Beyond it and she doesn't
want to uh contradict anything that um
that t'challa's family in his Dynasty uh
had claim over I I think she's kind of
like a she could be an ambassador uh in
in ways that because you know whenever
you know t'challa was kind of that
natural Ambassador when he went to the
United Nations but raimondo was kind of
like
[__] oh y'all like I don't I don't want
I don't care about diplomacy but you
need someone who can kind of be that
diplomatic figure who um who doesn't
have to worry about like the domestic
policy of wakanda and I think akoye
could really do a good job with that
that's where I think umbaku will find
his strength I think he's going to be a
really good Diplomat now especially that
growth between the first movie and this
movie and recognizing that he has to be
there for a lot of the people and stand
for the people I think he's more Ramona
than Okoye could be but like in a not
like a better position but in a more
generous position if that makes sense he
comes with a little bit more kindness
than Ramona has because she's lost
everything but to go with your other
part about the I think that is the
opening I think she has more of a
storyline as a Midnight Angel than she
does as the queen of wakanda and that is
the storyline that I do want to see her
play into more especially when that
deleted scene is so good of like I'm
gonna go wherever this suit takes me I'm
like you just released Everett Ross and
I thought you were going to go back to
wakanda I assumed you were just going to
go back to wakanda with that suit but
now where is he and where are you going
you're now the white Vision we don't
know where you are
sure I mean that's why I think she
called it a spacesuit what if she goes
to space I mean the Marvel's at d23 we
saw footage of uh you know set to the
Beastie Boys music uh Monica Rambo Nick
Fury on a space station she's wearing a
spacesuit like there's a moment where
she gets like swapped places right and I
think she gets swap paces places with
Kamala Khan uh Kamala Khan's gonna end
up in a space suit I think is the
implication of that in orbit around
around Earth freaking out like what if
we get a moment where freaking saving
her from Sandra Bullock gravity and out
to space is Midnight Angel Okoye
scooping her back up bringing her back
to Nick Fury on the space station Martin
Freeman is hanging out there hopefully
with Chris Evans on that space station
old man Chris Evans wouldn't that be
great that's just my hobby pitch I I
think it would be amazing but it's also
like a Mark II suit Who's Gonna Keep
re-upping it when she goes to space and
it explodes
okay fair enough I've seen Harry Styles
hairstyle saves her yeah I'll take that
look I'll take that story
I mean she needs a redesign on that suit
that suit I think is a little
it's probably unlikely we see her in in
the Marvels but I like where your heads
I like the idea of getting her out into
space like that is such a like she is so
far been a semi-grounded character right
and then I think now with the wakanda
forever that's starting to push a little
bit more into the the tech side of
things that's it's interesting yeah I
mean I I've let go of my expectations
when it comes to like who Mike cameo in
whatever movie because I never would
have imagined Julia Lee Dreyfus would
show up in wakanda Forever that to me
still on the other side of the movie
makes no sense why she's in this movie
but Marvel loves to just
we also could have lived without it I
think it was fine we totally could have
but that's just like the nature of the
Marvel I mean Kevin feige loves this he
loves just being like this person's also
best friends with this person this
person used to be College roommates with
that guy like but I do think that also
it goes back to what I was saying about
like how just convoluted the process and
production of this movie was where again
seeing these deleted scenes it seems so
dramatically different I wouldn't be
surprised if there are deleted scenes
which Julia Louis Dreyfus that make a
lot more sense and like maybe set things
up and actually have a conclusion to it
in this where it's not just the Age of
Ultron thing of like hey there's a lot
of plot points here that we'll get to in
other movies like I I feel like there
there must be something missing with the
American side of the story in wakanda
Forever
Eric did you do this so they in the
original screenplay they did get more
talking points but they deleted it out
but I also don't think it added to the
story overall this part but they she had
a longer portion in the original
screenplay they just ended up wiping it
yeah
um and and just I think you and I
debated over this where uh when we
ranked our phase four titles and I made
the the horrible sin of not ranking
wakan forever number one or number two
but like I think I think really what
that movie would have benefited from is
having just like the movie itself and
then having two to three tie-in stories
that release on Disney plus that just
could have had the the reread subplot
the the Martin free the you know Everett
Ross and and Val subplot and then that
way we could just watch these just watch
the the shuri story the shuri Redemption
story I think was a perfect story yeah
after listening to the podcast it
started shining a lot of light to like
putting Riri Williams in there and I
still stand by that and I I also love
that character but the Martin Freeman
and the Julie Larry Dreyfus part was
kind of
it was weird I don't know it was yeah I
don't know I don't know what to say
about it it was a lot of movies that
already happened it didn't really helped
me but I guess you have you don't have
to but it's probably best to put Everett
Ross in there he was in the first one
put him in this one but they kind of
just kind of gave him like a little here
you go there's your scenes I think it
was a holdover from you know uh God
bless uh Ryan coogler he's been so
transparent and candid about his whole
process throughout all this and like the
more he talks about the more I realize
how hard it was for him to make this
movie specifically because that original
draft that he had sounded really cool
like it was a really cool movie and I
think he wanted to preserve as much as
he possibly could from that draft
because there was some like really
creative there's a lot of Beauty in in
what he had written and I think part of
it was that was originally going to be a
war plot with like the US invasion of
wakanda and I think uh Everett Ross was
a big part of that and so I think that
makes I think what we saw was just kind
of like derivative but just like just
the necessities of what he felt needed
to be still in that like to see with
Toby Ziegler you know over the state
department and they're all talking like
I think that was the holdover from all
that but really I think what he needed
was someone from Marvel Studios just to
be like hey you can lose this entire
thing you don't need any of it do you
think we see it come back though like do
you think that like the original ideas
and Concepts that that he had not the
first script that we end up seeing maybe
in Thunderbolts or something yeah I
think so I think that's probably why
Kevin feige and Nate Moore were like
maybe leave it in because yeah I think
it's gonna tie in with Captain America 4
or Thunderbolts or one of those we
didn't know that she was the CIA the
head of the CIA up until that moment so
I think that part was very important to
be like well
important enough for us so when we do
see armor Wars or even Iron Heart we're
like oh we know who's in charge and what
her motives are or not motives
completely but what she how what led her
up to this moment yeah I think that's
why they needed to just establish that
popcorn which you know watching the
movie the first time I really loved
learning that she was head of the CIA I
was like cool cool I love that she was
married to him once I was like oh my God
I love it and then afterwards I was like
why is this in here
yeah
if you think we see her in ironheart oh
yeah I think they're still after her
dude they're still after her she still
wanted yeah I don't right I don't know
because I kind of get the divide that
ironheart is going to be a little bit
more of its own story and like not so
connected of course there will be the
tendrils and things but I feel like I
don't know if we're gonna get that level
of like the grounded the government's
after your story uh in in Iron yeah for
whatever reason I think it's more likely
we see her in secret Invasion than
ironheart just because secret Invasion
looks like we're gonna meet the
president on the show there's might be
some kind of like presidential political
Intrigue so it makes sense that we'd
also see the CIA director on that show
you know secret invasion is after armor
Wars or before before before I think
secret division is next on the Slate
coming in May next and then we have oh
the next series yeah the next series and
then armor is now gonna be a movie that
I think comes out probably 2024 would be
my guess we don't have a release date
yet I thought it was later though maybe
yeah I thought I thought that was like
pushed 20 times I think you're right I
don't think we know
any moment they're gonna be like
everything's
you know there is another
um actually there's another deleted
scene with Everett Ross we're we're
speaking about him so uh we're gonna dig
into that and how that actually might
set up something in iron heart talk
about that in a bit first we want to
thank some people who helped us make
this episode thank you to nordvpn for
sponsoring this episode have you ever
had a situation where you wanted to
watch one of your favorite movies or
series only to discover that it's not
currently streaming in your country well
one way to get more content options in
your life is to check out nordvpn with
nordvpn you can change your virtual
location with just one click which makes
it easier to find streaming platforms at
a lower price we can even access
platforms that aren't available in the
United States with just one click you
can choose from over 5400 servers in
over 60 countries personally I use
nordvp in a lot when I'm doing research
for a breakdown like if I need to look
at a cinematic reference I need to have
access to tons of content that might not
be streaming in the United States but
thanks to nordvpn I can complete my
research and get you all those sweet
sweet breakdowns that you crave Plus
nordvpn's benefits and features go Way
Beyond improving your streaming
experience you can also access games and
discounts only available in other
regions and block malware written
websites while you explore securely we
encourage you to try nordvpn for
yourself so grab your exclusive nordvpn
deal by going to nordvpn.com Marvel to
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus for additional months for free
it's completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee that's
n-o-r-d-vpn.com Marvel for an exclusive
discount plus four months free we also
want to thank Turbo Tax for sponsoring
this episode go to Turbo Tax and don't
do your taxes meet with an expert who
will do them for you Turbo Tax experts
can relieve you from the stress of taxes
and file for you so you can do not taxes
show your eyes things that are not taxes
unpack a movie box of not taxes taste
not taxes a sing not taxes a lullaby
hope not taxes sleeps through the night
grab a saddle and ride not taxes into
the sunset with Turbo Tax and expert
will do your tax taxes from start to
finish ensuring your taxes are done
right guaranteed so you can relax feels
good to be done with your taxes doesn't
it come to Turbo Tax and don't do your
taxes visit turbotax.com to learn more
Intuit TurboTax full service products
only video meeting while expert does
your taxes required see guarantee
details at turbotax.com guarantees all
right let's get back into it I want to
know what Marvel's hiding about riri's
computer because another deleted scene
shows Everett Ross doing some spycraft
around the NSA this is after shuri and
Riri get kidnapped by Namor but before
Nakia goes down to rescue them Everett
Ross helps the wakandan sneak into the
NSA where they are hacking into riri's
laptop these NSA agents Ross uses camoyo
beads to scan the laptop as well he's in
Disguise from Clive some other NSA
colleague who screwed up some Tehran
mission that Everett Ross was on in the
past but he has to flush these uh
Cambodia beads down a toilet pipe
upstairs so that the community can
remotely scan through the concrete to
this laptop but the weirdest thing about
this scene is is that you know marvel
decided to blur out riri's laptop in
these scenes now it could just be a
licensing thing like Marvel maybe didn't
want to pay the licensing for what would
be a deleted scene extra I still think
that's kind of weird
um could there just to completely blur
it as opposed to use VFX to just like
patch this one little thing or to just
not even worry about it but I I wonder
if there might be something else about
the design because it looks like there's
a big red design something about the
laptop itself that might tell us about
what kind of tech Riri might use in
ironheart and they want to reveal it in
Iron Heart what do you guys think am I
reading too much into it yes I mean you
gotta imagine that's what it is right
then like it's like it I feel like we've
seen this before with uh the deleted
scenes in particular where Marvel tends
to not even release deleted scenes if
there's a big reveal in them or if
there's something that like actually
adds to the lore or to the Canon of what
they're the building in the story
um so having said that I could see them
blurring it out if it reveals even hints
what the suit the new version of the
suit is going to look like they don't
even want to like commit to that at all
at this point and they'd rather have it
be a moment in reveal when we see it in
the in the show
um or it could not be its suit design it
could have even just been like reference
to some other type of tech or like
something a reference to a movie that
we've already seen some Stark something
or other but
um you know the likeliest outcome is
that it was some licensing situation and
they they just had to blur it because
they're like it's not worth dealing with
yes I agree sorry I agree completely
that they ultimately were like but
um I also like that she did bring up and
I'm an idiot I um don't understand
anything you cannot ask me about physics
you can't ask me about math but she
brought up something in the in the movie
about like a Quantum something that she
had the schematics on her computer for a
drive for something she made on the
computer and as soon as she said Quantum
I immediately went to the fact that she
probably helped Cassie Lang Build That
device that two-way device for the
quantumania trailer and so if there was
something on that computer that was a
connection to quantumania they have
probably since got rid of it or were
like let's just get rid of it because
her movie involved or her series
involves Mephisto we don't need to have
her involved in quantumania and Kang
right now uh so maybe that could have
been potentially it yeah I like I like
what you're thinking I wondered that too
when they said she had to use like a
Quantum encryption uh in order to like
to encode her laptop and that's like
these these NSA agents would have to and
like why use the word Quantum you know
so loaded in the MCU so I like I like
that idea a lot Jessica and I I uh I
just wonder I think you're right it
probably is like just some kind of
Licensing thing but what laptop do you
have to blur the entire laptop for the
entire device I understand blurring the
logo on it but this is distracting in
the scene maybe maybe it was blur just
because they didn't have actual assets
on it like maybe they're just like it'd
be weird to like it's unfinished bfx or
something and they're like it's easier
to just blur it to release this this
deleted scene than to actually go in and
you know do whatever they were going to
do you're right Tim although I have seen
some real potatoey looking Hulk footage
from deleted season infinity War where
his arm is clipping through his knee and
they let us see that crap so I don't
know that is true but you know having
said that though I feel like some of
these scenes like these scenes look for
the most part finished right it's like
they look like they could just be
straight up deleted from the actual
movie and it would have been fine so
it's not like the you know the early
storyboard stuff and and it is the Hulk
obviously much more uh work has to go
into that than a computer screen but
still decide they know that there are
YouTube channels that are going to
dissect every single thing so anything
they put there even if it's just
placeholder to them they're probably
like oh it's not even worth the smoke
here that's sure I also as a
um I was once a production coordinator
Once Upon a Time uh in the digital world
so it was much easier but when we had to
send things to Legal they had to approve
of every section so we would highlight
it and it would have to still be
approved even if it was like a Lacroix
can in one scene and a little crank it
and another scene they had to approve of
both scenes so if this was a deleted
scene but oh get rid of it get rid of it
and they had to if they had it deleted
from post that means they weren't
approved of it after it because it
already went sent out so maybe it is a
form of something that's like it was
never approved by legal
show it but we can blur it out
um but I still like the idea the Deep
dive of like there was something hidden
on there that they just didn't want to
get into right now because sometimes you
do that sometimes they do that they're
like we just don't want to get into it
that's very possible
um all right some fine just a quick
final thought I want to engage from each
of you
um when we're taping this just a couple
hours ago James Gunn announced his full
DC slate uh uh Jess went into this with
uh with Tommy and with Brandon on the
break room did a great job reacting that
I I summarized it in a quick breakdown
video if you want to check that out but
right now we don't we can't really tell
exactly what these uh titles will look
and feel like right because we don't
really have a baseline movie or trailer
anything any footage we don't know who's
gonna be directing these titles who's
gonna be acting in these titles all we
really have is just like James Gunn's
pitch for it but how are you guys
feeling about the state of DC moving
forward versus the state of Marvel
moving forward do you think it's
possible that James Gunn's DC Universe
you know three years from now we might
be saying
these movies have all been really good
in some of these Marvel movies haven't
been that good Brandon brought this up
and it's a it's through Brandon through
koi genre that they both need
competition they both we need the
highest form of intelligence from both
of them to make really good products so
I think that competition is going to be
healthy and needed with that being said
as an adult as an adult I am so excited
for what the DC has to offer because I
think a lot of their products are
getting into a Zone that's more depth in
dialogue more depth and discussion and
Marvel hasn't been giving me that but
it's also like my nephew isn't gonna sit
down and watch the game of thrones style
of Wonder Woman but he is going to watch
Ant-Man so it's like it's different
audiences I think it's approaching so
for me personally as an as a grown woman
I'm so excited for what the DC is going
to offer I am going to devour it and I
hope Marvel can give him a run for their
money I hope so I hope so yeah I mean I
believe in James Gunn and I feel like
he's given us us nothing but reason too
right at this point whether it's Marvel
or DC it's just been hit after hit and I
I think in uh terms of what you're
saying Eric of like he just gave the
pitch he's already kind of been given
the pitch like starting back even with
Suicide Squad and especially Peacemaker
right so I think that the man behind
those projects is now going to be behind
the rest of these in some way shape or
form and I think that that gives us a
really good idea about what the tone and
Vibe is and uh Jessica talking about the
more adult tone Concepts all of that I
think that that's really clear when you
look at this pipeline of how they're
going to handle some of the the
different properties here and especially
being able to play with animation and we
know that James is going to push that to
its limits of uh what it can be and
we've seen success with that recently
with things like invincible and uh even
the boys presents diabolical
um the little Anthology series like I
imagine that uh James being able to have
that James Gunn style playing with the
most obscure characters you possibly can
and that's kind of his tried and true
thing but what about when he gets to
play with Superman and Batman and I
think that that is what's obviously the
most exciting part of this the DC versus
Marvel thing I mean I just hope that DC
can step it up and have consistent wins
back to back to back because we've seen
Marvel do that for years and sure we can
all look at it and be like Oh phase four
is is this or that or whatever it is
I've still had a great time with every
single Marvel property and I I'm looking
at the next couple years and I'm really
excited I think the the hardest part for
DC besides just getting the movies right
which I I have faith that they're going
to do now because of James gone and the
team that they have over there it's the
fact that they're going to be competing
with a phase five phase six Marvel
they're gonna be like I think that right
now phase four we're kind of like oh
yeah it's a setup phase whatever but by
the time we're getting Superman and
stuff that's gonna be going directly
head to head with the lead up to
Avengers so the competition is great but
I think the stat the odds are stacked
pretty against DC at this point agreed I
think the the tent poles that Marvel is
uh is is gearing up toward are just
gonna be pretty hard to compete against
but I think just I think I'm more
excited from this announcement of the
HBO series that they've announced doing
a Waller series a lantern series The
Paradise Lost like all these sound
really cool I know you love the Green
Lantern one lanterns it's a True
Detective like that shows me that the
team they have are willing to take
interesting choices like that's more
exciting to me than like I mean what we
actually got from like 411 Thunder which
I if you were to pitch me the movie that
that actually was I don't know I I what
what like it's just kind of a weird
confusing project of just like cool
moments that are stitched together but
that's not the story that that was was
very confusing
I don't know what that is yeah that's
true and what I what I enjoyed the most
about what James Gunn did today when he
talks about all the the DCU and the
future of it all was compare things to
properties that we know and love like
comparing Paradise Lost to
um Game of Thrones comparing the uh uh
lanterns to True Detective immediately
we understand the prestige there like we
understand what they're trying to
accomplish and it's more than just put
out as much content as possible on
streaming platforms like I get the vibe
that they are going to treat both
Lantern and Waller
um and prepared Us lost as Prestige HBO
television show Sunday night Main Event
Last of Us succession placement uh shows
and we get to boost your gold and I
think that that's going to be more the
HBO Max streaming side and I know HBO
Max and HBO there technically isn't a
difference but we all know there is we
know that if they put it on that Sunday
night spot it has more going into it and
that's what excites me most good for
them
I worked at IGN back in 2014 and I
remember it was during E3 which is like
the Super Bowl of video game news and
we're like in the War Room covering all
the video game news and while that was
happening all of a sudden it was like oh
DC just announced an entire lineup of
their movies and it was like and then
there's the Wonder Woman and then
there's the Flash and then there's this
and we're all like
there's no way this is actually gonna
happen and to now be here 10 years later
and be like wow most of those movies
actually happened some of them still
haven't happened and most of them have
been some level of disaster some of them
have been pleasant surprises right but I
think where we're at right now is very
sad and messy and complicated because we
still have years until the DCU kicks off
like in its entirety we still have the
DC EU to contend with and where is that
that point my biggest problem with the
James gun stuff today there was about
four different points he's like this is
the start of the DCU this the um the
what was it called creatures oh
Commandos
creature command is gonna be the first
actual DCU thing and then later it's
like the Superman movies the true start
of the DC and it's like oh man there's
too many starts here too many stars The
Flash is the reason it's just his
keywords he loves using those words he
uses them all the time yeah hey we'll
see how this goes um but we'll still be
talking Marvel here on inside Marvel
from now through the end of time both
leave it there for this episode uh hey
uh Tim thank you so much for joining
Jessica and me today this is a lot of
fun thank you for having me I'm really
really excited to be here I gotta get
you on our shows at some point too I
would love to do that
um hopefully we'll be able to put
something together soon in the meantime
be sure to subscribe to new rockstars
you can follow Jessica at Lulu
underscore Clemons you can follow Tim at
Tim Gettys uh and of course be sure to
subscribe to the kind of funny Channel
they're always doing amazing amazing
content over there and while you're at
it uh new Rockstar's spinning off a new
channel called The Deep dive that's
going to be launching February 17th so
subscribe there hit the notification
Bell because if it's not already on the
channel right now uh we will sometime
soon have a channel trailer so you can
get a sneak peek at all the stuff we're
working on over there and of course
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcast and we'll see you next
week bye bye everyone
Sailor Moon
[Music]